this presentation is delivered by the
Stanford center for professional
development I would like to introduce
take an opportunity to introduce Ryan
chin he is the associate director for
the professional programs at Stanford
center for professional development he
is responsible for ensuring programs
delivered programs delivered the
Stanford experience as well as working
with partners to build new and existing
programs he has over six years
experience with the Stanford center for
professional development which includes
serving as the Associate Director of
Marketing welcome Ryan Thank You Casey
I'd also like to introduce professor
bill Burnett bill is a consulting
assistant professor in mechanical
engineering and currently the executive
director of the design program he
manages the undergraduate and graduate
programs in design at Stanford both join
programs between the mechanical
engineering department and the art
department
he received his BS and MS in product
design at Stanford please welcome Bill
thanks Stacey
I'd also like to introduce dr. mark char
mark works at in the Center for design
research at Stanford he is a member of
the symbiotic project project of
affective neuroscience lab or span lab
at Stanford he is a lecturer in the
School of Engineering Mark's area of
research is the intersection of design
thinking and the neuroscience choice
where he has several research projects
underway mark comes to us from a 30-year
career in industry as a vice president
with the Procter & Gamble Company in the
senior vice president and chief
marketing officer with the Intuit here
in Silicon Valley please welcome mark hi
Stacy and with that let's get today's
webinar started thank you everyone so
this is my cue to start
well good morning everyone and today
bill and I will be talking to you about
a concept called design thinking and how
that impacts the art of innovation and
how you can use both
those concepts design thinking and
innovation in your work everyday work
environment uh here ooh look I'm going
to start off with a very simple poll I
want to ask you what is you what is your
current impression of the concept of
design thinking towards design thinking
what do you think that means and it's
thinking like an artist painter or
sculptor thinking like a graphic
illustrator thinking like an interior
decorator or frankly I don't know a very
popular answer among academics give you
a few minutes to think about this all
right I can see that that will say most
people think that it is thinking like an
artist painter or sculptor and indeed
that's an aspect of it but it isn't
entirely in fact even mostly what design
thinking about is about less so people
think it's thinking like a graphic
illustrator or thinking like an interior
decorator again also popular concepts
for what design might mean and roughly a
third people say I just don't know and
that's good too because if we do our job
today at the seminar you'll have a much
better understanding of what design
thinking is all about so let's let's
move forward I'm pushing the button and
could you advance the slides thank you
up design thinking is a lot like this
picture and if you can imagine at the
standing at the top of a mountain with a
rock in your hand and should you let
that rock go there's really only one
thing that's going to happen it's going
to roll down the hill and very little
will stop it and what you can see is at
the very top you essentially have a
choice do I drop it on this side of the
mountain or do I drop it on that side of
the mountain because once you have
dropped it the rest of it is essentially
execution so for the big questions in
life and in business design thinking
sits at the very top of the mountain it
helps you decide which path you're going
to take forward and and in our con
what we do is take the concept of design
and transition it from design to our
concept of what we call design thinking
ranging from the neurology associated
with design to to how you solve problems
with design and design thinking has many
aspects to it I can touch on the
strategies used to make decisions the
systems and experiences involved in in a
product or product development the art
of invention or innovation coming up
with new ideas and then looking into the
future how do you use Design Thinking to
establish visions moving forward okay
and our concise way of saying what
design thinking is about is it's a it's
a framework it's a it's a way to frame
problems creatively and generate
innovation innovative solutions
strategies systems and paradigms at the
Nexus of domains and what we mean by
that is a Design Thinking is
particularly useful as a process that
spans domains of thinking or domains of
experience or domains of expertise it
works best at the edges and it helps
people frame problems and develop
solutions as a result in that here's a
here's an interesting example as it
applies to athletics and in this case
it's the high jump if you simply plot
the world record holders over the last
sort of hundred and twelve years you'll
see that there have been along the way
paradigm shifts there have been ways in
which people have executed this maneuver
that have resulted in jump shifts in
results starting with the scissors case
in the 1900s the Western roll which
became popular in the early 20th century
the straddle kick and then finally the
more modern way of approaching it the
Fosbury flop now it's still a human
being and it's still a bar and it's
still a certain distance above the
ground but the techniques and the
paradigms by which people practiced it
went through a series of changes and
what happened at those nexuses of change
what caused people to rican sieve of it
now if
clearly an integrated approach because
actually in the 1900s they were jumping
over the bar and landing in a bale of
hay and whereas today they jump over the
bar and they land in a and a hi-tech air
infused material that allows Falls from
higher levels without without injury and
shoes have changed athletic clothing has
changed and certainly trading has change
as a result of it so there are allied
technologies but in the end it was the
approach of how one propels themselves
over over a bar and the various
techniques that go through that that
caused these paradigm shifts over time
ok so now what I'm going to do is I'm
going to ask an additional poll question
and then I'm going to hand it over to
Bill so as you think about your company
your current work environment where you
are today how easy or hard is it for
your company or your work situation to
adopt a radically new idea it's easy
it's great it's easy but there are some
challenges it's difficult but doable or
it's very difficult bordering on
impossible I'll give you a moment to
think about it
and these are not unusual results almost
everyone finds change particularly
changing the concept of a radical new
idea that shifts the paradigm and shifts
a business model very difficult in some
cases it can be done in some cases it's
downright impossible and you can see
right here we've got roughly 70% of
people saying it's difficult and a large
percentage of folks saying bordering on
impossible in my organization so Design
Thinking is something that first and
foremost can help you within your
organization and secondarily can help
the team you work with quite directly
and then longer-term has the possibility
and potential of shifting and changing
your entire company culture so with that
I'm going to hand it off to Bill
and he's going to take you through
culture thanks mark
you know I'm mark been to a whole bunch
of pretty big concepts here rather
quickly and I want to kind of ground it
back down to the organizations that you
work in the teams that you work on and
actually the individual yourself how do
you how do you create the environment
and the possibility of these big
paradigm changes you know I always say
that if you give any you know smart
group of people a problem they're
probably going to come up with a pretty
good answer and so assuming that you all
work in organizations where there's lots
of smart people and teams that are
really dedicated to working you know
hard to create great solutions in
business or in nonprofits whether you
work in products or services smart teams
typically come up with good answers the
problem is the girls have been changing
lately that you know good answers don't
tend to be enough anymore and part of
that is because the outside world is
changing at a more rapid pace than ever
before new competitors are entering
market places new offerings are entering
market places that sort of you know just
completely change the value proposition
of business models that used to be
highly successful before before the
internet before Google before you know
kind of the cloud storage your cloud
systems you know had evolved Microsoft
made a very good business that grew very
rapidly selling shrink-wrapped software
selling a package of software in a box
that would do word processing a package
that would make slides like the ones we
were looking at today and any number of
new entrants into the marketplace have
put it kind of assaulted that
shrink-wrap software model and even
Microsoft recognizes that it's no longer
a viable model if they want to grow
aggressively and take advantage of all
the new users on the internet I can the
favorite quote of mine from the science
fiction writer William Gibson is that
the future is already here it's just
unevenly distributed and I have the
privilege of working with young students
who are you know between 18 and 25 or 26
everyday and for them the future they
live in the future but the many of us
have yet to experience they don't use
Microsoft Word or Excel or PowerPoint
they build all of their presentations
and documents in the cloud using things
like Google Docs and and applications
from small startups that most of us have
never heard of they don't buy iTunes
anymore because that's so that's so 2005
they they stream all of their music with
Spotify and Rhapsody and Pandora they
don't watch television the dorms are
full of large screen TVs sitting in in
the dorm sort of common spaces that are
never turned on because this is a
generation that consumes all of its
media on mobile devices laptops iPads
and cell phones they they present their
final projects on YouTube and they live
completely in a digital universe that's
something that most of us so they don't
use they don't use email anymore
everything is text and chat so that's
something that a lot of us haven't yet
adopted is as practices but it's a sort
of emblematic of this sense that while
things are changing so fast and
solutions that smart teams used to come
up with before don't last very long if
they work at all and so how do you get
into a place where innovation occurs
regularly David Kelly's fond of saying
you know we teach kids to innovate
regularly here at Stanford but that's
also an oxymoron because innovation is a
one-time thing and regularity imagines
you could do it you know systematically
and as a process and we do have a
process diagram we talk about you know
sort of five steps of Design Thinking
but I want to talk a little bit
differently than that at first and talk
about design thinking as culture as a
way in which organizations operate
because cultures are just the sort of
spoken and unspoken set of rules under
which when we come to work or we you
know go to an event we know we are
expected to act when we go to a movie
we're expected to sit in a dark
auditorium in one chair with our cell
phones off and passively watch a film we
don't expect people to do other things
than that so we talk about design
thinking as a culture and it's about
creating a culture that has certain new
norms it is about a culture of creative
confidence if you get an opportunity
david kelly just did a TED talk at the
last tech conference on creative
confidence linking the work of a
psychologist here at Stanford Albert
bandura who has studied how people
achieve self authorship self-efficacy
and has a model for that and it turns
out what we do to teach people how to be
more innovative is very much along the
lines of what bandura has been studying
for years it's a notion of rien gauging
people's I'm everyone is creative so
naturally but they've lost the ability
to be as creative as they were as a
child because of a bunch of
of norms and socialization so what we do
in a design thinking culture is try to
rekindle that sense of creative
confidence we use a lot of techniques in
the ideation bloc of our model to teach
people to really access their massively
parallel unconscious thinking that
happens all the time
how to reconnect to all forms of
thinking not just intellectual rational
but emotional kinesthetic visual
thinking and through training in these
techniques teams become more facile at
having good ideas and following their
intuition we talked about design
thinking sitting at the Nexus of domains
which sounds sort of technical it's
really just about what we call radical
collaboration I often talk to people in
business and they I say do you form
teams and say yeah and they say are they
are they cross-functional teams I say oh
absolutely we've got engineers from four
different departments and I go well
that's not really what we were talking
about do you have sales people on those
teams do you have people from the field
on those teams you have customers on
this teams so you have folks from
accounting folks from marketing folks
from you know parts of the company all
of whom have to at some point or other
interact with the output of this team's
work and it turns out that that seems to
be a pretty challenging things in most
organizations now I can't imagine a more
siloed more bureaucratic organization
than a university and even a university
like Stanford known for its innovative
approaches to education and things is a
pretty siloed place professors who teach
in you know communications or business
or anthropology or sociology hardly ever
have an opportunity run in to socialize
or certainly not work with professors
from computer science engineering our
you know physics but here you see a
picture of a group of faculty actually
in the very very first D school
building which was a little 20 by 40
foot trailer that we borrow it over in
the corner of campus because there was
no space when we started and the
gentleman on the upper right with the
white hair and glasses on his laptop
that's Terry Winograd one of the major
major forces in computer science one of
the early AI pioneers and then really
one of the inventors of the user
interface user experience side of
computer science and in the very back
corner the other gentleman with the
white hair looking towards us is burning
around who's one of the world's leading
experts in kinematics which is a form of
motion mechanics tena Selig with the big
smile and in the middle I think carving
up a pumpkin or something there she's
the executive director of the Maine
management science and engineering
program so we've got three completely
different departments in the school
planning a class together and obviously
enjoying it so when we talk about the
nexus of domains we're talking about
mixing people who have different
languages different frames of reference
different ways of looking at a problem
and we find that when you do that if you
can manage the sort of discontinuity
between the semantics people used to
describe the same things the way in
which they frame problems if you give
them some training and explanations for
how to radically collaborate we we get
sort of really amazing in linear results
from those kinds of teams we start our
whole process with what we see if you
look at our process diagram you'd see
the very first step is empathy and we
like to believe that we create cultures
of empathy it's a it's an it's somewhat
of an unusual sort of emotional even a
soft word to introduce into the culture
of business we don't often think of
business as being empathic but what we
believe is that any smart team given a
problem will come up with a good answer
but the team that connects their their
work to the actual human experience the
human need behind whatever problem they
are trying to solve will be the one that
has more and better data they will come
up with this interesting both emotional
and and usability information that comes
from the direct observation of their
users this says also some seems to be
one of the more radical notions in our
in our idea about design thinking often
when we talk with people executives and
other people from the business community
we say you know do you use empathy in
your work and they say what do you mean
and say well you know how often do you
talk to your customers they go oh well
we've got lots of customer data we have
market research data we have data from
the field salespeople we have data and
typically they're talking about
customers being the people they sell to
for instance in in the tool industry we
sell to Home Depot and Lowe's so we
talked to the Home Depot and Lowe's
buyers we know our customer very well
but when we actually say have you ever
talked to somebody who's trying to hang
a picture and they've got a hammer and a
nail and a piece of wire and you know a
picture that they want to put up in the
wall and have you ever watched them
tried to do that and understand the
difficulty they have positioning a
picture correctly leveling the picture
getting it to hang the way they want it
the frustration they have with finding a
stud and all the other things they go oh
why would we do that you know we don't
sell to them we sell to Lowe's and we
find that breaking down that barrier
going that that that last mile to the
actual customer and using the tools that
we take from anthropology and
ethnography to do observation of
customer needs and this can be in a
service product like designing a new
service for a bank or financial
institution can be in a product product
I was seven years at Apple Computer
before I came to Stanford
we despite the rumor that the Apple does
no market research which is kind of true
they do tons and tons of empathy
research to make products as simple and
easy and in
as apple products typically are you need
to really understand where people get
stuck and how they miss and understand
the use of products so we do a lot of
work in the empathy area and we do that
upfront to sort of load up a team a
smart team with information that most
other teams don't have and this is
partly how we unlock the problem as Mark
said because I'm thinking is more about
problem finding than it is problem
solving you know again most Martin teams
are great a problem solving the trick is
getting them to work on the correct
problem and often we find that it takes
a deep dives with the real users
involved in the problem you're trying to
solve and a lot of direct observation of
the users in their environment
understand what is frustrating them if
the users can't tell you what they need
they can't say well if you would
redesign your product like this it would
be perfect but they can show you what
they're frustrated with and they can
show you the difference between what
they say and do they may say you know
it's this fine I don't have any problems
and then when you watch them you
discover all the little workarounds that
they're doing in order to get their job
done so that's the data that we think
really tends to unlock the problem and
allow us to step back and reframe the
problem as not what everybody else is
working on but something new so if you
create this culture of creativity and a
culture of empathy the next thing you do
is you you teach people how to have a
culture of ideas where ideas are hard
and you never you're never working off
of one idea or two ideas or three ideas
but that you start every process
generating literally hundreds of ideas
I'm in the middle of teaching the class
right now because thing called the
summer arts intensive and it is not
uncommon for a design team in that class
when given a design challenge they have
a maybe a 24 hour challenge to sit down
a brainstorm using brainstorming and
other techniques that we've taught them
and generate two or three hundred ideas
prior to going through a selection
process
what they really want to work on to
build and we find that although most
people say they brainstorm and most
people say yeah you know we have plenty
of ideas around here when you really dig
down in you sort of metric what's going
on people are working one inside a very
limited range of ideas around a central
theme and to that they don't have
literally hundreds and hundreds of ideas
so if you generate a lot of ideas and
you link those ideas to your
observations your empathy observations
of user needs your tends to redefine
problems in a way that really create I'm
kind of new value the other thing is
prototyping and this is an intern oh
this is an interesting example of
somebody growing some weird little thing
together and it looks kind of crappy and
it's kind of rough and that's exactly
the sort of stuff we encourage see the
thing here is that you're working on
what is called a classically quick good
problem if you're really trying to
redefine your industry or just redefine
how you submit expense reports you know
up through the food chain and get them
signed off no matter what the level of
problem is if the problem has people
involved in it then the problem is a
classically wicked problem and we could
problems don't have good solutions they
just have better and worse they don't
have you know right solutions they just
have stuff that will work for now and
typically once you've proposed a
solution to a problem and it's ok new
problems emerged and this probably
describes almost everything we work on
nowadays when we're redesigning services
or we're taking on you know the
challenge of working in development
developing countries and providing
solutions for water agriculture poverty
and other things the problems are big
and they're very messy and no matter how
well defined you think your your problem
statement is and no matter how well
you've brainstormed and come up with
many many ideas it turns out as soon as
you start building something new
problems emerge and so we really really
believe in the concept of failing early
and failing often failing at a very low
resolution so that people can try things
and and discover the facts as they go
forward people often say well why is
design-thinking different than anything
else it's just a problem-solving tool
but I think this prototyping thing is
one of the things that makes it quite
different and I'm trained as an engineer
and I use a lot of engineering thinking
when I have a tightly bound problem and
I have enough equation so I can solve
the problem and find the unknown in
engineering thinking you solve your way
forward you you find the one right
answer because you can behind you know
put the problem in a small in a box so
that it can be solved if you know
business schools teach another form of
thinking I'd call it business thinking
where you're making decisions you're
deciding your way forward the data isn't
quite as clean let's say as engineering
data can sometimes be but you still have
a figure of Merit this company makes
more money than that company's more
profitable their return on assets is
better in a versus B the strategic fit
and five for quarters five forces or a
SWOT analysis tells me the strategic fit
of a is better than B so there there are
ways of making decisions and creating
some figure of Merit around the
decision-making so in engineering we
solve our way forward and in business we
decide our way forward but when you run
across problems where there is no way to
get enough data to make a accurate
decision and you certainly can't solve
for anything's because people are
involved so it's too messy we believe
you build your way forward you literally
build solutions to inquire into the
problem to get to the next layer of the
problem so these prototypes that we're
talking about these rough prototypes are
designed to fail they are very low
resolution they typically leave out a
lot of data but they're designed to pose
a question and there are another way of
inquiring with the user in the same way
that we use empathy to sort of see what
is going on in the situation and how
might a really simple prototype it was
it the next level of discussion so we
really view prototypes as a way of
asking questions creating a social
dialogue with users the other thing by
the way the prototypes do which is sort
of
but quite wonderful his prototypes get
the design team or the team working on
the problem
I'll grounded together often how many
times have you been on a team where
everybody thought we all knew exactly
what we were talking about then when we
made the slides and went to do the
presentation we all went that's not what
we're talking about is it prototypes
helped us pull the team together
and then ask questions you know out in
the world where the real problem exists
um I want to I want to just yeah I close
with this quote so no Design Thinking
culture is a culture of creative
confidence that uses prototypes to
inquire about the world it's a culture
of ideas and it generates ideas in a
very flexible and fluid manner and it is
fundamentally you know about setting up
the conditions that allow people to fail
early fail often so they can succeed
sooner and it deals with a class of
problems but neither business thinking
or engineering thinking is equipped to
solve that we all have a process and
this is a great quote this from a friend
of mine over at the business school
Allen Millay lee's CEO of Ford was
walking through one of the Ford
engineering buildings and one of the
young engineers who was frustrated with
the fact that you know Ford was a
process driven company they had stage
gates for every decision there was and
dozens and dozens of metrics around how
decisions would move from one stage gate
to the next to the next to the next and
yet this was pre bailout this was back
probably you know the early 2000s Ford
was failing to make cars that people
wanted to buy and everybody was a bit
stumped and they were refining their
processes and trying to you know
six-sigma their innovation engines and
and wonder why they weren't making cars
with anybody liked anyway Allan's
walking through the lunch room and a
young engineer put up a sign says that
said culture eats process for lunch and
he said who found the kitty so what are
you talking about is listen you know
I've only been here five years but it's
clear to me that Ford is not a car
culture we seem to care more about stage
gates and
and coming up with numbers and metrics
than we care about making cars that
people really really love and Miley to
his credit so step back and thought
about it and he realized he was managing
the wrong things he was man you know
what managers do is they have systems of
information and control finances a way
of managing financial information and
controlling the rate of spending and
what is invested in you can manage
process which is important and certainly
everybody has stage gates for innovation
but he realized that the managing
process was not emphasizing the kind of
culture he wanted to create to cut that
in fact Ford wasn't a car culture that
they had lost their passion for building
great cars and he realized that culture
is probably the most important thing
that a manager manages and again
cultures had invisible set of rules
about what does it mean to come to work
today and what are you going to do what
the engineer young engineer was telling
him is that when I come to work what I
expect to do is fill out a lot of
paperwork and answer a lot of questions
about where I am in my process but I
don't come in and read all the car
magazines and go out to the studio and
talk to the designers and go out to the
you know racetracks and talk to their
people who really really love you know
what the Ford Mustang represents in
terms of an iconic piece of technology
in our culture and Melilla changed his
mind to change the way he was managing
things Ford has been rather successful
actually the only company that didn't
take a bailout and he he credits it to
the fact that he started managing a
different kind of control system he
managed culture rather than process so I
always always learned that quote because
it it's you know you can we have a
design thinking process that starts with
empathy then we redefined the problem
then we go to an ideation prototyping
and testing but ultimately if you
understand that what you're changing
first is yourself the culture of
yourself what you plan to do when you
come to work today are you going to just
write a lot of emails and do a lot of
things you
make some time for innovation and ideas
once you've decided to manage yourself
differently you can always manage your
group differently the five people you
work with and instead of worrying about
where you are in the process you want to
be mindful of that but you also want to
be you know thinking about how are we
creating a culture of ideas today how
are we up in people's creative
confidence today and what are we doing
to engage our users with some tangible
objects prototypes of services
experiences whatever to get some data
and you know how are we asking the
important questions if you come into
work with that attitude you'd be
surprised at how much you can change so
it's really um you know like are you
doing things right but most people you
know worry about if your process-driven
you're worried about you doing things
right are you crossing all the t's and
dot all the eyes but Design Thinking
asks a different question
are you doing the right thing are you
actually solving the right problem in
thirty years of consulting and I'm sure
mark would agree with me on this
typically the people who bring you know
consulting problems to to my firm or to
Stanford I've brought the wrong problem
and most typically what they brought us
is symptom not the end underlying
solution so if you take the time to stop
and ask the question am i doing the
right thing rather than doing things
right your are often at that top of the
mountain when you're ready to let go of
that Boulder but you really should be
thinking about am I looking at root
causes am I looking at data from real
individuals and real users or am I just
moving through a process are you
managing the present and we're all I
think stuck in this problem of you know
the tyranny of the immediate but you
should be thinking certainly as a
manager or as a group leader of how are
you creating the future they're one of
the reasons that the rate of change is
so overwhelming is that we're constantly
caught up in sort of trying to manage
this present
where the rules keep changing and we're
not quite sure where we are versus
taking some time to put into the culture
this notion of creation Roger Martin who
is a Dean at the Rotman School of
Management at SU Tron in Toronto the
Business School there was a design
thinking advocate wrote a book called
the design of business you could look at
that if you're interested in the
business text Roger says it shouldn't be
an MBA which is the management of
Business Administration because he
doesn't think he's teaching people to
administer things he wants to make it an
MVC a management of business creation
because that's actually what what what
you should be working on how are we
creating a future that's sustainable and
that grows it's a blue ocean that's you
know that's new and different if you
have an opportunity to ask those
questions at least some percentage of
your time shifting it from the managing
the present to creating the future
you're starting to build a culture of
design thinking and fundamentally it's
about changing you know decided changing
paradigms we were working with a
probably the world's leading the largest
supplier of industrial parts for both
the auto industry the white goods
industry you know this is a major
multinational organization and they are
expert leaders in providing components
to a number of key industries but there
are sort of stuck gun you know the
growth rate is stagnant you know if
you're supplying parts of the auto
industry it's been a tough 10 years you
know things change slowly if you're a
component supplier your treat often
treated like a commodity and so margins
were eroding and they wanted to try to
take a design thinking approach and
after a couple of brainstorming sessions
some frame working workshops and a
couple of days of work we kind of came
to a very simple kind of description of
what they needed to do they needed to
move from supplying a component you know
a shock absorber to a vehicle to
thinking about how the shock absorber is
a part of a system
of traction control it's a part of a
system of autonomous driving it's coming
coming very quickly you know to vehicles
near you and from moving from a
components to a systems orientation
would require them to work differently
different parts of their organization
who provide individual components would
have to radically Corral collaborate to
provide new systems solutions to the
automakers but that was one thing that
they agreed would probably generate huge
amounts of opportunity they make a lot
of sensors you know vehicles washing
machines everything has sensors in a
temperature sensors water sensors
pressure sensors but if you think of
sensors it's just an object that goes in
a machine then it's a commodity if you
think of a sensor as part of a smart
network it becomes a completely
different play many times you know
people think of the things that they
sell our products the products can
always be turned into services where I'm
working right now with a company that
makes some probably the premier
manufacturer of plumbing parts in
America and if you think of yourself as
a plumbing manufacturer you think of
yourself you know turning brass and
steel into valves and faucets but if you
think about how water could be
considered a service rather than a piece
of plumbing you can completely change
your business model and then this notion
of standalone devices to the cloud
particularly the auto industry we have a
center here professor Chris Grady's runs
the Center for Automotive Research at
Stanford cars and we're working on
autonomous vehicles we had one of the
first autonomous vehicles to win the
DARPA challenge we are working with
Volvo who has a Volvo 2020 sort of
future of the car project and they were
telling us that in by 2020 there will be
more bandwidth between the car and the
Internet's car in the cloud than you
have in your home today and the cars
will be once cars are connected to the
cloud and to each other the issues of
autonomous driving and finding other
ways to provide you know services where
we used to consider cars a standalone
vehicle now they'll be connected in
networks through the cloud and the
potential for that in terms of car
safety car autonomy and
in entertainment systems and details
it's just enormous so this is an example
of how moving from one paradigm to the
other could radically change this
organizations business and they are in
process of putting in place all four of
these initiatives worldwide across their
organization
Alan Kay who's a computer scientist the
inventor of a Dinah book the first book
and was an Apple fellow said it probably
better than anybody the best way to
predict the future is to invent it
that's what we did at Apple when I was
there for seven years they're still
doing it I guess they're going to have
some new phone announcement tomorrow but
I don't know I love my iPhone it's the
best pocket computer I've ever owned but
it's sexual reception as a cellphone has
never pressed me but I think if you
think about better than managing the
present inventing the future an
opportunity to really change the
paradigm in your organization so this is
all the stuff we talked about at the
Masters Series mark you want a term you
lock us through well I'll pick up
actually duel in a class like this yeah
so this is a will now give you a few
minutes as to what actually happens at
an Innovation Master Series we focus on
I would say four domains of knowledge
the first is something we call the
Design Thinking model which I'll show
you in just a minute and some of the
tools that underpin that they are full
of hands-on exercises because we believe
can aesthetically the best way to learn
is by involving all of your senses so
each one of the lectures focuses some
kind of hands-on experiment or hands-on
experience that reinforces the
underlying aspects of of the learning we
also really build your creative and
innovative muscle we provide you and
allow you to practice with a whole
series of creative and innovative skills
and these are skills that you can take
back to your co-workers and facilitate
within your own work groups and finally
the people that come to this our folks
that are just like you they are
struggling with the same kind of
problems you struggle with but in a
different industry or in a
in context and meeting them and talking
through those spending three days
together provides a series of
connections and context that can be
quite helpful as you move as you move
forward the innovation master series is
for people who are masters folks that
have been in industry for a period of
time who have experienced success and
failure and are looking to as Stephen
Covey calls it sharpen the saw and as a
result most people have between 10 and
15 years of experience by the time they
come to an innovation master series and
having that kind of peer group sitting
around tables is a very stimulating way
of doing this the context for an
innovation master series which is the
context for the way in which design is
practiced at Stanford is really the
intersection of three domains we spend a
lot of time talking about human values
how usable or desirable something is
empathy is a key tool in this area we
also talk about the technology that
underpins that how technology can be
used to meet those human needs and
finally there's a business aspect to it
these ideas have to earn their way in
the marketplace to provide viability and
sustainability on the right hand side
here you'll see this is a plaque that
sits in the in the d.school
and it talks about sort of the guiding
principles of how we approach design at
Stanford it really is about the
development of innovative innovators
innovative skills breakthrough thinkers
who can deliver the future today it uses
this concept called design thinking in a
multi disciplinary team environment
it focuses on collaboration bringing in
people who might not normally be
involved in a process and teaching them
how to work together and get the most
out of their interaction and finally it
focuses on really big ideas big projects
big ideas ideas that will change the
world
and and make make the world a different
place the actual Design Thinking model
looks something like this
I liken this to if you're a cook you'll
understand this a chef a cooker chef
there are things called recipes and
recipes are guidelines for success and
if you're new to cooking you tend to
follow the recipe very closely if you're
an experienced cook or a chef you can
look at a recipe and almost taste it in
your mind and and really we catch people
in all stages of innovative thinking in
this process so we start with a very
basic recipe if you will and this is the
design thinking model it's a 2 5 node
model and it and it's an iterative model
so at every step along the way you can
iterate if you will from the right to
the left and continue looping through
this begins as bill talked about with
empathy really understanding that the
customer that you're trying to satisfy
with your work there's a definitional
element as they'll talk about working on
the right things and learning how to
reframe problems and work on the right
kind of problems as opposed to just
doing the problems right there's an
ideation step where you generate you
learn how to generate ideas in a in a
new way a way that perhaps you have it
in the past and then an important part
of what Stanford is about is taking
those ideas from just a series of
neurons firing in your brain to
something physical or tangible in the
real world and that's called prototyping
and you'll learn how to do that
within your corporate environment the
various ways in which you can prototype
and how you can learn through
prototyping and of course the concept
then is once you have a prototype to
test it to see how well it meets the
needs that you had originally identified
and then to iterate to return back to
ideation or to return a definition or
even empathy again and work through the
process on the right hand side you'll
see here's a series of tools that you'll
be exposed to I can't say we'll go
through every one of them in great depth
but you'll you'll have the opportunity
to learn about each one and some of them
will be practiced
quite extensively but it'll help you
build your toolkit and it will help you
bring back to
organization a whole series of of ways
in which you might be able to practice
innovation in a different sort of way
so I'd like to take a poll just to find
out from your standpoint how you would
apply design thinking in your own
organization and this helps us guide the
content of what this may be about would
you guide it with what we'll call
product development the development of
physical tangible product would you
guide it with service development or
services in elements are you interested
are you primarily a services business
and I understood that and we should open
it says the poll is closed as polls are
closed we'll see if we can open this
you're probably click madly clicking
away and nothing's happening okay polls
are open should be up there you go are
you interested in both products and
services and would like to see how they
both interplay or is it you just don't
know enough to say how you would apply
design thinking in your organization all
right good good
well almost two thirds of folks say
we're interested in both products and
services and I think we have heard that
and in the in the curriculum we're
identifying for December we're going to
be being dealing with both sides of this
issue both products and services to
provide them a balanced approach here if
you move forward here are the here's a
rough look at the people that will be
speaking and an innovation master series
what distinguishes this kind of
experience is that each of these people
is a professor at Stanford you're
talking with people that are both
researchers salad researchers in their
own right and gifted instructors and are
on the cutting edge in many instances of
the field in which they work you get a
sense that it's a wide-ranging process
from learning how to id8 as bill takes
you through an ideation tune-up then
David will talk about design thinking
and his concept of creative confidence
and how you build confidence
Bernie has a delightful talk about
choosing the right thing
working on the right problem he calls it
the question is the answer
mark uses biology bio-inspired design to
help people think through problems by
using metaphors from nature how nature
solves problems and what that might mean
and it's a great way of learning how to
use metaphorical thinking to help
stimulate stimulate your own thinking
about your own business situation alison
has a very interesting exercise around
touch and the empathy of touch and how
that can involve design thinking we have
a session on prototyping which area
sherry and Ed run which teaches you how
to do prototyping in your own
environment Larry will talk about teams
and how design teams practice we've got
to service a segment that I will lead
and finally Banny will talk to talk to
you about design as strategy how you can
use design to to help formulate more
effective business strategies along the
way will will facilitate a tour of I do
you'll have a chance to visit the
research labs here and see how people
are actually doing research using design
thinking and there'll be a reception at
one of our automotive lamps the
Volkswagen lab that will show you how
design thing is actually being practiced
in in industry the date for our for our
next Innovation Masters series is
December 12th or 14th it's a Wednesday
through Friday begins Wednesday about 1
p.m.
closes Friday about 4 p.m. and we have
can take 56 participants we have 30
enrolled so far in fact ready to start
up this morning or 39 and roll so we
have a limited attendant but if you are
interested I would contact Stacy with
the information right here as quickly as
possible it's likely we'll do another
innovation Masters Series in June and
that will give you another another
chance of this but the December the
December class will be quite special so
with that I will turn it over to
questions we've been answering some
questions that have been
mitad but if you have questions we'll
take a few of them and respect our hours
time with you such a charm professor
Bernette thank you so much for that
terrific presentation so again my name
is Ryan Chen I'm the associate director
the Stanford center for professional
development just going to quickly go
through a some of these the Stanford
center for professional development has
been as part of the School of
Engineering and we've actually been
delivering professional education but
for the graduate programs and
professional education for over 50 years
it's really been a pleasure to work with
many of our faculty our charges to make
sure that that we take some of the great
research and the great knowledge that we
have here and make sure that we can
deliver it to people who are working in
industry and have you apply it to what
you're doing I am going to then say that
the reinforce that the innovation master
series again is June 20th to the 22nd oh
I'm sorry yeah them one day sir a little
more importantly it just importantly as
a date should I say the other one is
that I want to bring up is the nature of
this course I'm getting static and so
I'm sorry can you hear me this is as
Professor Shaw had said is really kind
of a hands-on course it has lectures and
exercises I know we take them out both
in the design school itself we take them
out to the areas on the Stanford to
experience what they're learning or
including tours of I do and I think that
you will you will find and have sign
that the faculty that you work with is
infinite will learn from are exceptional
and the opportunity to interact with
them is really unparalleled one of the
ones that you can win let's go ahead and
read who should attend but I'd like to
go back in the heart to go reflect back
on the course that we just recently ran
in June and that who came and we had in
representatives from the oil and gas
industry energy industry hospitality
medical device clothing
that and of course the high tech
industries in software and hardware we
have teams come I think it's very it's a
really a great opportunity if you want
to try to get this thinking and get this
practice into your private into your
company coming with a team would be
valuable and then a way to make sure
that you can then spread that out not
just one person but too many okay and
what I'm really I'm just going to really
quickly just go to the rest of them here
are key takeaways one of the ones that I
really want to just mention on this one
is that if you hadn't heard from it now
it is truly an honor and a pleasure to
be able to work with the professor's to
have your questions answered directly
their passion their knowledge really
comes through this is based on the work
of the research they're doing in the
graduate teach and they're doing it's
really a terrific opportunity to deal
with them directly as for the faculty
but let you read this again and these
stripe slides will be shared one of the
things that I want to point out is that
for many of our professors and
instructors they have industry
experience so not only do they have they
done the research and really delve
deeply but they've actually didn't
worked out industry and apply it at
you'll have an opportunity to visit
professor kotovsky lab and see what I
thought was a terrific application and
Biodesign they get the Gecko robot well
you can learn more if you come to some
of the course let me just skip lastly to
the poll here and ask what is your
current interest in the Design Thinking
course and let me just pause having
people after that
okay well thank you so much we're gonna
try to get back in touch with everybody
who asked for more information we really
appreciate that
again of course is December 12 to the
14th
there is a earlier registration discount
of $500
so all that registration deadline is
coming up quickly you can see the
customer service there and I know that
had we just shared also Stacey's
information before - I think we'll try I
think we have a few questions and maybe
we'll take a few moments to answer those
so other than that I just want to thank
again professor Shaw and professor
Bernette for joining us today and giving
us this opportunity we deeply appreciate
it I mean thank you so much for
everybody who I was able to join us we
again will be posting this online and
we'll be sending this out and the slides
alright alright and we're going to stay
online to answer those questions again
we really deeply appreciate everybody
for joining us with you because this
morning thank you
you